interrate the whitest altri nuovo talent
come sempre chiesto sempre di pareggiare
sgomitare anche se lo vince sempre per
fortuna comunque quest'anno vanta le tre
che riesce a fare il rebus live più
bello abbiamo a disposizione le con le
colorate in più metteremo una che era un
qualcosa in modo che non vediamo cosa fa
l'altra persona questo ancora meglio
in realtà io volevo fare un video in cui
mi schiavo tutte queste cose e vedevo
che colore usciva
ho pertanto lì invece di mischia triste
perché non possiamo lasciare tutti
almeno possiamo entrambi chiare tutte
più o meno e vediamo chi essere meglio
ognuno può usare la tecnica che vuole e
alla fine vediamo come uscito vi faremo
vedere lo style e come sempre dovrete
votare chi vince e dovrete votare lo
slime dovrete dare un pò do una 10 per
aspetto e un voto da 1 a 10 persone a
fmr quindi diete i fronti prendete
patatine pop corn itaca fare il tifo per
me non so come si fanno sono sicuro di
vincere
sono fortunata perché magari sono
fortunato anche adesso vedremo comunque
mettete micron ieri abbiamo subito ci
siamo posizionati allora non sapevo cosa
mettere i bears e pacifico
detto questo aspetto la delle lol e ora
3 2 1 via allo spezia
allora tu puoi usare tutte le cose che
voi in quanto molte voi quelli definiti
come farlo basta che non combinare
ovunque inguaggiato la corsa
allora ragazzo ha deciso di mettere una
multa cioè cosa trasparente con la
bianca chi vuole può prendere un pò di
cola gas prende un po di colla bianca a
seconda di come quel che scattino
titolare ma qui sono qua è teso aggiungo
subito contro di pollo ruspante non mi
viene che lo sto facendo
strani il disastro bene sono contento
soddisfatto così ecco io finalmente
allora come sta andando bene pensi che
sia bene la fotogrammetria timer magari
perché non andiamo troppo con calma
magari la prossima silence facciamo uno
slide con il timer e vediamo come riesce
a farlo più bello entro e con
prestabilito diteci voi che tengono
fermo mettere magari non 30 secondi che
ci sta cantano in grande in passato
dalla stazione di letteralmente agli
occhi vino che dovrebbe fare l'albero
che l'hai capito come le capita farebbe
che bicolori che sto facendo
[Musica]
e che sto andando fortissimo di fuga
forse non sempre vinto
vincerò io vedremo vedremo
poi è tornato per ora sto benissimo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
perché non essere veloce e sono tesi
giallo rosa che colore è la tribuna però
va da tutto il giallo ma sono spot non
c'è struttura camorra che ci siamo quasi
con altri finito il tutto tra un po
abbiamo a vederli a paragonarli ma che
io guardi pista ok
sei pronto un secondo ora dobbiamo
sistemarlo mese per fare la
presentazione quindi per quando me lo
farà in vedere quindi se passerete cosa
stare nel tempo è oscar del tempo solo
perché grido tutti adesso mi aspetto
questo aspettare per troppo tempo ci
siamo ci siamo ci sei ancora un po di
soluzione per me che sono però che lei
anch'io
secondo ei aperti no sennò non durerà
michelin così che si aiuta tantissimo
[Musica]
perché non ero tutto linea del cane
perché dice bellissimo con il mondo
della presentazione allora ecco il mio
ecco quello di vitale ancora dobbiamo
farli vedere bene queste sono i miei
colori celeste viola rotta giallo e
azzurro invece i tuoi sono celeste
fragola andrà nostro un fragola è unico
non incarna bene governo ecco che con la
famiglia perché tito marrone e del
router colore marrone e coca cola
poi da verde viola unicorno rosso
fragola sulle specie lo scaduto 0 più
belli miei colori cura che me lo devi
dire per certo che fa prevedere al bene
fuori non garantisco perché siccome è
stato progettato per essere appunto un
ciottolato proviamo visto la premiazione
la destra
guardate guardate vi stupirò ancora più
bello di quello che temono guaio è
bellissimo tempo all'attacco regolamente
evidente basta per capire come mai
questa cosa spinge e l'unicorno che s'è
sentito ma la comunità che beppe rosso
fragola stupendo e vero no diteglielo
conti stupende rosso fragola
mammamia guardami stack in questa
maniera in griglia ma sia un attimo
l'aveva data fa gola pc cosa da ridere
poi dopo che me li facciamo vedere il
meglio andiamo anche rischiarli e
vediamo di che colore diventa
no io giambellino 2 diventerà un carro
nei profitti montati bello strumento che
ti dico cosa è bellissimo ha un po un
alieno però la benedizione chiuderlo
budella allora ragazzi
ecco qua il mio galaxy slime ora lo
mischiato già un po meglio la signora
bimbo rainbow quindi i colori si sono un
po già mischiati comunque potete vedere
i vari colori corratec delle sfumature
che brilla tv poi andiamo piano piano
mischiano così vediamo di che colore
diventa a dopo doppiate spot e allora
date un voto da 1 a 10 per l'aspetto e
pericolo riguardanti che belle sfumature
e ora vi faccio sentire i suo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora non essendoci schiuma da barba
nell'azione non fa moltissimi suoni
poking però fa un po di suoni di bolle e
ora potete anche vedere come il colore
da mischiato è diventato una sorta di
verdolino verde acqua i glitter si
vedono ancora bene quindi la maledizione
degli slam ferri di anita a fare una
volta però è un po mezzo celeste con
quindi votate per aspetto sia quando era
rainbow sia il colore finale che per
suoni a smr e ora tocca vitale che
abbiamo il nostro slime ciotola lo slang
come potete vedere ha mantenuto un po i
colori come una ciotola lembo si vedono
ancora un po i colori però purtroppo lo
mischiato prima per fare la
rappresentazione quindi se si era un po
galaxy dato diciamo adesso andiamo a
tirarlo fuori dalla ciotola
guardate
troppo bello un galaxy un re rainbow
galante che la regola era il rainbow che
il galaxy fantastico cioè dai non ha
paragone questo tipo quel celestino di
anita
io non vedo perché è stupendo quanto è
stupendo poi andiamo a mischiarlo
vediamo già sta assumendo sta sta
prendendo tutti i colori terreno sta
assumendo questa corona se colorazione
così un po colore ecco che con andata
male essere solo mischiamo e facciamo un
po di rumore ma che bello
i brillantini che s'intravedono
bellissime cr embo il galaxy la
costellazione tutti vogliamo metterla
guardate che bello questo colore chiaro
[Musica]
bellissimo poi cordate quanto si allunga
e allungare si allunga proprio che
allunga tantissimo se non facciamo
subito qui facciamo una bella sfida
bravissimo nello stupendo ora facciamo i
suoni
non fa il pochino perché non c'è la
schiuma da barba come ha detto unito ben
vengano i dati però e non è bellissimo
guardate come la consistenza perfetta
usare dosare proprio che si chiama di
bicarbonato dalla soluzione per lenti
non si rompe si allunga ma non si rompe
un po di tempo
ora che bello e ti amo lino digitò
perché legge rosa invidio cosa ho fatto
troppo bene leonardo lo stima il tuo
mettiamo di una piazza all'altra ma
ormai la presentazione i rumori super
scoppiettante presentazioni stato
setacciato ecco il mio guardate che bel
colore verde acqua bertolino glitterato
vediamo il tuo ma che colore è secondo
voi stretto coloro trasparente che
includono l'universo il galaxy
allora per quale votate per il mio
quello di vitale voto colore suo niente
mr colori durante vince vitale mi
raccomando vita lena votate vitale nei
commenti perché stupendo parla del
cappello stupendo ma le ragazze allora
li avete visti bene gli heat live fatte
nei commenti vediamo
cosa che vince anche se secondo me il
tuo ha un colore un po strano e
bellissimo e bellissimo votate nei
commenti consigliate sicure quali altre
challenge fare scrive tecere tutte nei
commenti
e allora rilasso qua quattro catene
stuzzicare se volete vedere le nostre
altre strade da stevens che altri live
video divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona migliore ciao